con la condena de cadena perpetua del
policía wayne cousins quien secuestró
violó y asesinó a la joven de 33 años
ahora en el sur de londres en marzo se
abre un debate bien importante y es que
tan segura es la capital británica para
las mujeres pero además sobre el abuso
de la autoridad por parte de la policía
dado que este policía utilizó su
uniforme su banda que lo acreditaba como
un integrante de la fuerza pública para
detener a la joven porque supuestamente
estaba rompiendo con las reglas del
confinamiento de la pandemia aquí en
londres de hecho han pedido que la jefa
de la policía la comisionada crecida de
que renuncie para que pueda darse una
investigación al respecto la diputada
con más años en el parlamento harriet
harman ha dicho que crecida dic debe
irse para que se investigue porque había
demasiadas señales de alerta sobre el
comportamiento del policía asesino y que
fueron escondidas debajo de la alfombra
por supuesto este caso como
horrorizado inmovilizado a millones de
personas aquí en el reino unido-
especialmente a mujeres que claman que
piden que estos hechos no vuelvan a
repetirse el primer ministro boris
johnson dice estar conmocionado
horrorizado por lo que se ha conocido en
este juicio que se ha adelantado aquí en
londres y ha dicho que las personas en
este país deben sentirse seguras
caminando en las calles y deben tener la
certeza y la confianza en la policía